the nice meeting you everyone so today I
will present you a framework for uh
privacy friendly AI so I guess you see
my screen just little disclaimer uh you
so you might have seen Bastion AI but we
improved we extended version yet to
cover more things as I will discuss so
it's now called bathroom lab but okay
just little
note so today I will talk about how to
make it easier to Trend AR models on
confidential data especially in
multi-party setups
you might know this case uh which is
actually called First Learning but as a
reminder the issue is the challenge is
how can I help train an air model on
several party's data sets because uh
have your diverse set of data helps how
the modernism more accurate less
positive less false negatives and uh you
know generalize better which can be
critical in some applications such as
healthcare for the diagnosis for
instance
those issue is yeah how can you help
those data owners collaborate without
risking the privacy of each hospitals
one method you might know of is called
FedEx learning which is quite popular
today that's been democratized by Google
and the idea is that okay
because data is a bit sensitive we might
not move it directly but we're going to
move the gradients uh to train the model
so we have a data scientist who you know
designed the model send it to an
aggregator to aggregator dispatches as a
model to each hospital then the hospital
using the local computer machines
train their model locally
get the gradients and then send the
gradient back to the aggregator and then
the emulator will aggregate the
gradients get a new model run a splash
it and we work select this in the loop
so it looks useful that it's working but
there are a lot of issues actually
the first one is deployment because you
might have seen that each Hospital must
perform the competition themselves and
therefore each participant needs to have
the hardware and software stack to run
the competition which can be quite quite
difficult if you imagine that will Trend
like for instance some gpt-free models
that require huge gpus
you might not think that every hospital
that is participating have this and even
in terms of deployment and maintenance
needs always uh you know update everyone
which can be quite difficult
then there is an issue of communication
because as we move the gradients at each
iteration it is quite expensive and
again if you have large models that
means large gradients and therefore a
huge communication bottleneck
and finally even though the data is not
set and clear gradients can be
and in most Frameworks ingredients are
extending clear which is a which can
pose a privacy issue because you can
reverse engineer more or less easily the
data from the gradients and also you
don't know what kind if each participate
each participant
put the right data in the model and you
have no Integrity of data and
computation
in this framework and for all these
reasons battery learning is still a lot
of challenges
they promote communication being the
biggest obstacles for an easy deployment
so to answer this issue uh we'll propose
a new framework but to understand how it
works we need first to understand what
is confidential Computing which is a key
uh technological component of a solution
so for those of you who might not be
aware of confidential Computing it's the
use of hardware-based trusted education
environments to secure data while it is
being used by someone else
the idea is that some processors that
you might find today from Intel AMD or
Nvidia have the ability to create a
secure environment so that your data can
be handled by someone else remotely
without them seeing your data
as we'll see one of the first major
property is what we call data induced
protection so that can someone else not
in your residue remotely in the first
two you do not master
can compute things on your data without
them seeing it thanks to some end-to-end
encryption mechanism
the second key feature is what we call
code adaptation which provides
cryptographic proof that only a code you
know and trust is executed on your data
and therefore you can have integrity of
data and computation
what does it mean that data is protected
during analysis
the idea is that whenever we have
sensitive data to have to have someone
to handle it remotely for instance in
that case a trend and AI models on your
data remotely then we will use we will
do this in a secure Enclave which is uh
a kind of
um Black Box environment while there is
Hardware protection whether it is
isolation or inclusion of memory so that
even if I am a club
an AI startup in let's say edible us
and I want to train an air model on new
data that you send me and when I say you
I can let's say a hospital well if that
data is being handled inside an enclave
even me as an administrator of the VM
will not be able to see the data that is
being manipulated by our machines even
though we uh somehow manage it because
there is this kind of Hardware uh
protection mechanism
that is that okay that's great that's
suppose I want you to manipulate my data
and I know that because you're doing
secure Enclave you will not see it in
clear because it's only accessible in
this secure environment that you do not
you cannot uh compromise but then the
question is
how can I know that even if you're just
a secure Enclave that you actually have
one because maybe you are not using one
so there is no guarantee or maybe you
put a malicious code that is leaking the
data outside of the secure parameter and
that's why there's a mechanism called
code Integrity with a promoted station
and the idea is that before the client
that has a hospital sends data for
someone else to try to model on it the
idea is that they will perform what we
call attestation
and those Hardware are specific CPU
instructions to generate a kind of
identity of The Enclave of the code that
will manipulate the sensitive data
and we could have information about
let's say I don't know like
uh what firmware we are using
um like a
some a lot of security parameters but
the most interesting one is that
would generate a hash of the code of the
enclave and would have it signed by a
key that is only available to the
hardware
each CPU or GPU with that fix your
enclave ability have tamper-proof
Hardware that are written on the
hardware so that they can sign it with a
key that is not accessible by the guy
who might manipulate the uh
uh The Enclave because as I mentioned
those keys are tamper-proof from the
outside and therefore that means that
once I've generated my item still is
enclave and I've signed it with the key
of The Enclave
I cannot Forge it I cannot Forge another
uh report that says look I am an enclave
because I don't have a Hardware Key
but of course you have uh to understand
um to make sure it is indeed one Enclave
you will then send that report to the
hardware provider let's say for instance
Intel and they have the list of the keys
that are embedded on their uh on the
CPUs is solder and they can verify that
oh okay yosho Amy uh some kind of
identity of an enclave it is signed by
the key that indeed comes from one of my
CPUs and then it says okay I will attest
that this is indeed a genuine uh sexual
Enclave
reports and I will send it back to the
user
is that the user will uh check that uh
forces Intel as indeed signed it
entirely that case would be the root of
trust and then we say okay
if it is indeed what it says I know that
actually I'm talking to a secure Enclave
with the right security properties
especially
I know that there's a specific hash of a
code that is loaded inside the enclave
and therefore if I have if the code is
open source I can reconstrate the Ash
and compare the ash that I am expecting
the cache Observer and if those hashes
don't match that means that there is
some malicious code or at least that's
not the right code behind
so I've been talking a lot it's it's a
lot of stuff to handle so I guess it's
good to have a little demo
uh to see how it works in practice so
you can go to this uh
space from a new face where we'll see
how it works with a perfect example
uh I will let you have a look or maybe I
can I can put that in the chat after
what
I'll just wait 10 seconds
I guess I can put that in the chat
uh
so uh which is and let me show you uh
how it looks like
uh let me show you the screen
okay
so this is an example on
um on hugging face and that is that
we'll see what we need to use a secure
Enclave so to use this account lab it's
a bit like going from HTTP to https in
the sense that
okay I've put three servers behind one
server without Enclave
and because there is no secure Enclave
ability
uh I have no guarantees that my data
will be protected that it will remain
end-to-end encrypted
but because there is no attestation
linked to this I can detect that even
before send data I can detect it as much
as you know uh when you're using I don't
know HTTP when your browser goes on a
new https website you can detect it well
this is the same thing there is some
security check that is failing
and even if okay
shouldn't react
to start it
okay
okay I guess this is a demo effect
okay let's try directly is it okay okay
little issue
okay so I guess I will show it and I
have an example and I have another
recording
so I will uh send it but uh yeah I can
imagine that uh it detects the error and
then uh
once it walks
I mean so I did that if there's a
management Scott will detect it because
we'll observe that there is a wrong Ash
and if there is a red Ash
you can then use air models as usual
um okay I will uh go back to the rest of
the presentation
so sorry for this little issue I we have
recordings of times where it worked
I guess I should not have a
been so dishes and there is a demo
effect
that
um
let me show you I don't know if you see
my screen correctly okay
this one it's not the full screen sorry
okay let's get back to it
so now that we've talked about
confidential Computing very quickly
we saw that confidence are Computing can
allow you to have someone else analyze
your data without them saying it because
it remains end-to-end encrypted through
those Hardware Technologies
and the idea is that instead of using a
fertile approach will have a socialized
approach that would be much faster and
easier to perform but that will be
protected by secure enclaves and
therefore we have the Privacy guarantees
so that's what we call fortified
learning and the idea is
um
it will be much simpler the air provider
uploads the model inside the secure
Enclave
the hospitals plus a data set inside of
this there's a new trend everything
locally inside this single Enclave or
this cluster of enclaves
and the idea is that with this scenario
or the infrastructure effort can be
centralized in a single node
you don't need anymore to have each
Hospital have the CPU gpus needed on the
software to pay for computation because
computation is externalized to the
single node this vest making it much
easier
and actually
the only thing you need to have on the
hospital infrastructure is just the
patent package to remotely attest that
your target but this is very lightweight
you can imagine running that on a laptop
and therefore the hospitals could
send the model simply from a web browser
on a simple laptop
an extra Auto computation externally
and therefore it is much easier for them
to be onboarded and you can manage
everything therefore you don't you don't
need also to you know uh update your
software on each node because the update
can be concentrated inside the central
point
also in terms of communication we
communicate much less because everything
happens inside the single cluster there
is no need to go back and forth between
a node and a central uh aggregator
which make it much easier especially if
you train large models
in terms of security and privacy because
we're using secure enclaves data is a
model and the data and the updates are
hidden from anyone else thanks to
end-to-end protection and we have can
have integrated check as I mentioned
through attestation and therefore we
have integrity of data and computation
so how does it work in practice so does
that audio comes upload the data set
into the enclave send the data scientist
rheumately interact with it they never
have the data locally because it is the
same computational plans for instance
Trends such deep learning models
and once it's done
they can fetch the results
so we have one concrete example where we
fine-tune the Transformers on the
private data set with the function
privacy using Earth framework
screen
okay
so you can find it on Bastion lab this
is a GitHub
so as I mentioned bastionab is I can't
talk I can come back to this but
Bachelor
not only covers deep learning training
it also covers uh that exploration and
other things
and we are starting to merge it Western
AI into Bastion lab to make it
uh to have a unified framework for both
so here I will show you as directly when
I wrote the proposal for pi data it was
for Best in AI but now uh it's being
merged but uh you can still find the old
version AI uh repository inside but
within one or two weeks you will have a
clearer and unified framework
as I mentioned is uh
to uh to show how we can train an AI
model in this 45 learning framework the
idea that will provide the document
image that you Deploy on your secure
Hardware
and search Hardware can be found on gcp
or Azure for instance
since the data order gets the data set
for instance we look at data set for
spam classification
so do the pre-processing first in an
offline phase
the data scientists prepares and modeled
for instance adjustable classification
here
in an offline phase as well
and when they want to start trading
they go in the online phase
connects to secure enclave and performs
attestation
if there is any kind of error for
instance the secure Enclave there is no
proof that this is a secure Enclave also
code the Azure code is not the right one
uh an error will be front
raised and it will not continue any
further
but if it was we can upload a data set
remotely such as the SMS
contractification we can also Define a
privacy budget okay here it's a one
million but it's a very realistic but
you can put whatever you want
and the data scientist then connects to
the secure and clever monthly and you
can get a list of the Roma data sets
is this objects are just metadata that
he has locally that have information
about the robot data sets
and he will use that for instance
to create what we call a robot learner
this is a bit similar to a faster
Learners objects or you provide a model
and a data set but here will provide a
rumored data set so all this happens
inside the data scientist infrastructure
and therefore it doesn't have access to
the data set directly but only as a
pointer to that
then the certificate provide other
parameters for instance the last
Optimizer and so on and then you can
call a fit function
the fifth method will simply send
to the robot Enclave so instruction to
begin training
is uploaded on the remote data set
and with differential process
but when it's done when training is done
similar we can pull the model and get
the model locally using a get model
method
here it is a single data set scenarios
but covering the multiple data set
scenario is not hard where we'll just
have several data sets that have been
prepared that are merged
stacked into the enclave and the data
scientist will in the same manner just
trigger training on the whole
that is it
so let me go back to my slides
um
yes
now we can see some benchmarks of the
performance of our approach on the fine
tuning of an efficient net model
therefore for computer vision so this is
done on a
AMG epic CPU
so AMD has the
ability to create those confidential VMS
that provide as I mentioned the data in
use protection
and that's why we did the first
Benchmark on this and you can see there
are several Frameworks that have been
tested we're using we are using titles
without any Progressive mechanism as a
Baseline
library for differential privacy which
as you see greatly increases the trading
time the bigger uh
uh is what it is because it's amount of
time it takes to do one epoch
then you have a pythons with two nodes
which is a therefore in the Federated
manner and then you have bite off with
two nodes with differential privacy
which is the slowest one but with the
highest level of privacy in a Federated
approach you can see that Bastion AI
with differential privacy is actually
quite competitive because it is 10 times
faster than bad touch with differential
privacy
uh in the multiplier setup
we also have similar results on gpus
even though it's a less uh the
difference is not that big well you can
see that patosh in the Federated
approach with differential privacy is uh
three times slower than Bastion AI
with differential privacy
and so regarding confidential computing
as I mentioned this is something that is
getting hot and imagine okay you're
talking about Hardware but what if I
don't have the right CPU or gpus that
has those abilities well good thing most
Cloud providers now have confidential
Computing offer as you can see Azure
being one of the most leading Solutions
with both AMD
so Nvidia an Intel secure enclaves tea
earlier
and as I mentioned as you can see on the
bottom yes Intel has been the first one
but IMG followed uh quite quickly and
the interesting and good news is NVIDIA
will provide in the next uh Hopper GPU
Financial Computing abilities which was
not necessarily the case before and the
pharmacist opens a lot of opportunities
because before we could only use CPUs
but now you can imagine having a cluster
of Nvidia gpus to Trend uh AI models and
confidential data Financial Healthcare
Biometrics and so on without risking
privacy
so if you're interested I will be very
happy to talk uh with you we have a
Discord that we have recently
kick-started
that you can join I can share the link
and there is also we have two repository
one to deploy AI model which is called
Blind AI and one compassion lab that
covers training and also data
exploration and visualization
and so uh I don't know if there are any
questions but I'll be happy to answer
those